Bitola belle of the ball after putting
on a pair of Japanese rhinoceros beetle
earrings and burn rubber on your desk
driving a wireless sports car mouse
because it's episode 54 of loot the tiny
Tesla musical Tesla coil kit fittingly
allows you to build a Tesla coil that
can play music by heating the air and
creating pressure waves we hear as sound
you can order spare parts if it ever
breaks down and it comes with a USB
connection so you'll be listening to
MIDI Pirates of the Caribbean in no time
time to battle some helicopters with the
sky terminators RC helicopter set a pair
of RC copters that shoot lasers at each
other they have shields to help protect
their weak spot but if the copter gets
hit five times it goes down if you'd
rather build vehicles then shoot them
check out the air power racer kit a DIY
toy that teaches you about using air as
an alternate source of power the car
uses compressed air to propel itself and
move surprisingly fast build this
volleyball court with air on the water
the Aqua Glide super volley floating
volleyball court is an extension for the
super [ __ ] 35 which means that yes
Billy floating trampoline volleyball
just became a sport why not my name is
Lily sport these handmade pumps once you
decide to make it back to dry land
zombie peepshow sells custom shoes
clothing and accessories ranging from
allison Wunderland high heels to Jason
from Friday the 13th put water safety
first with the Kinji inflatable
flotation device designed to be worn on
your wrist like a watch the device is
unobtrusive and easy to activate simply
pull the lever and a bag will inflate
and stay buoyant for up to 48 hours and
it comes with an attached whistle to
signal for help
help yourself to some easy slushies with
Zoku breeze the inner core pour a
chilled beverage into the cup stir and
then watch as it freezes right before
your very eyes honey holes honey horse
of course it's
but can you drink from the handy horse
neigh you'll need the magical unicorn
champagne horn to fill your mystical
beverage holding needs if you need a
game that's powered by magnets try the
hovercraft levitating challenge that has
you stacking blocks on a hovering
platform adjust how stable the hover
platform is and it plays out like a
futuristic game of reverse Jenga reverse
your expectations for what candy should
taste like with these Stinger pops made
with the three hottest peppers in the
world so pick a pepper and pray you
don't end up needing first aid I'm
Shania I'm Tracy my hey those that
require cute and cuddly aid falling
asleep look no further than the sleep
aid copy a stuffed animal that when
activated lets out a gentle pulse for 20
minutes it's designed to help you
synchronize your breathing and heartbeat
so you can calm yourself when stress or
fall asleep when tired the beard bundle
will guarantee never tire of your beard
products the service sends a variety of
oil soaps and balms and you can choose
from three different levels of beard
care minimalist lumbersexual and
majestic take in the majesty of Mars
from your bedroom with bars in my room a
nightlight that depicts the Red Planet
in great detail and has points of light
to mark where the Mars rovers have
landed it also comes with a pack of Mars
Lander cards that give you information
on the different Mars missions Mars then
pile more planets stuff on your plate
with planet plates just keep your anus
in the cupboard if you're having a
dinner party after dinner sneak out with
the benign urban stealth bite a bicycle
inspired by the f-117 Nighthawk aircraft
the single speed bike comes with an
atomic 22 security system which renders
the bike useless to anyone without the
proper key and its carbon belt drive is
quieter than a chain doesn't need to be
greased and lasts longer you can't ride
a bike without some safety equipment
though so be sure to bring along a
chainmail keychain for protection which
you can attach to your constructor DIY
SLR camera a kit that lets you build
your own SLR camera all while learning
about how single-lens reflex cameras
actually work now that you've got a
camera like the scene with the pixel
stick an LED light painting wand that
you
used to create amazing time-lapse photos
put the image or design you want on an
SD card pop it into the wand and wave it
in front of a camera set to long
exposure but remember if you get my way
I've got one thing to say don't stop me
yeah sorry and as always thanks for
watching